ما هو منطقي اللي قاعد يصير
بالتوصيل المطاعم يعني بهالطريقه ما راح
يستمر مستحيل انه يستمر المطعم ما راح يتم
يدفع 30 واربعين وممكن يوصل 50% خلال
السنين القادمه مستحيل انه يستمر
بهالطريقه المطاعم اغلبها خسرانه ولو تسال
اي مطعم انت مرتاح في التطبيق موجود في
الوضع الحالي بيقول لك لا ماني مرتاح داش
وياي كشريك ياخذ مني كانه قاعد ياخذ نسبه
ضريبه ما هو هذا
فصار فيني اكيد في طريقه افضل الواحد ممكن
خلقت مشكله ورجعت تحله
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم اليوم بسولف مع عبد الله مطوع
مؤسس تطبيق كرج سابقا وتطبيق كاري مؤخرا
ضيفنا مره تجربه مثيره جدا للاهتمام بعد
ما اسس التطبيق في الكويت تم الاستحواذ
عليه من شركه دليفري الالمانيه بقيمه 180
مليون دولار
وتوسع البحرين وقطر والكويت والسعوديه ثم
بعدها بسنوات قليله قررت دليفري هيرو
وتقفل وتعتمد على تطبيقاتها الثانيه اللي
هي هنقرستيشن وطلبات وكل هذا من التاسيس
للاستحواذ للاغلاق صار في اربع سنوات
تقريبا فقط وهي فتره تعتبر قصيره جدا
بالنسبه للشركات الناشئه فبسولف اليوم مع
ضيفنا عن تجربته قبل وخلال تاسيس كرج كيف
اعرف الاستحواذ من دليفري هيرو تفاصيل
التفاوض حول الاستحواذ وش اتفق معهم عليه
مرورهم تجربتهم الى نهايتها في كرج في
توسعهم في مختلف الدول ودخوله في منافسه
مع شركات دليفري الاخرى زي هنقرستيشن
وطلبات بعدها بنناقش سبب عوده بتطبيق ثاني
لتوصيل الطلبات اسمه كاري وش المشكله اللي
يحاول يحلها لاصحاب المطاعم والمقاهي
وغيرهم والمحلات مع انه كان احد المساهمين
خلق هالمشكله في كرج وش نموذج العمل
الجديد يحاول يقدمه تفاصيله كيف بيقدر
يكون منافس لباقي تطبيقات التوصيل هل هو
اصلا دخل السوق متاخر ولا لا وغيرها من
الامور تخص التطبيقات توصيل الطعام بشكل
عام مثلا نموذج عمل الاشتراكات وغيرها
فترككم الان مع الحلقه عبد الله الله
يحييك قبل ما نبدا باللقاء اليوم ودي اعرف
صراحه تجربتك في الانقطاع السوشيال ميديا
انه احسوا شيء مستحيل انت مالك وجود
نهائيا في اي مكان
يعني خذيت قرار بالكورونا ان بالذات بعد
الزواج انه تزوجت انا قبل كورونا بسته
اشهر
فكنت ناطر يعني مثل كريتك البنت او مثل
شغله معينه تساعدني ان انا اقطع الموضوع
كان شهر العسل بالموضوع ان شاء الله جديد
وانا بالطياره انستجرام
حتى مو كبره
حذفت حساباتك والتطبيقات معنا اضافه
الحسابات والتطبيقات مره واحده واتساب
يحسب معها لا الواتساب هذا
فبس والله الامور تمام شهر العسل لاهي
سبحان الله البني ادم بسرعه يتعلم ويتعود
عقب الشهر رديت الامور طيبه
وصارت الكورونا وبالكورونا خذيت قرار ان
انا ما ابي اشوف ايش قاعد يصير في العالم
برا ما بيعرف ايش قاعد يصير خلاص كل واحد
ويا هلا ويا عائلتها قعدت بالقوقع اللي هو
فيه فكانت بالنسبه لي راحه نفسيه راحه
لانه ما قاعد اقارن نفسي
بالناس الثانيه ربعي وغيره فلان مسافر
فلان طالع فلان قاعد يسوي
فسبب لي يعني صراحه يعني نوع من الراحه
ارتحت وهميه الحين
الشباب اعطنا حسابك الوهمي نبي نبي نتابعك
نبي
ولو تبغى تتابع الحين
تبغى تعرف ايش الاحداث اللي صايره وش
الاخبار الجديده شوف ماخي من تقريبا 3
اشهر
حاشني فضول قلت برجع ونزلت انستغرام وهي
دشيت بسويله
نفس الاكاونت يعني فعلت
ودشيت وحتى تغير علي يعني سالفه
ومسرع ما انا يعني احب الهداياك واحب
القناص وهذا فمسرع ما اشوف فيديو الا
يطلعوا لي 3000 فيديو
الحين لا رديت خذيت الغرائع بشهر كان
امسحها فالحين رديت الى العصر الحجري مره
ثانيه ما عندي لا انستغرام ولا غير فرق
معك واجد ولا والله على حياتك الشخصيه شوف
فرق علي من ناحيه انه قمت اذا مثلا بقضي
وقتي طبيعي واحد يبطل بطل بطل على استخدام
الجوال
اكثر انه مثلا ادش
اشوف مثلا اخبار يعني محليه اقرا عن امور
معينه ما كنت اتقرا عنها قبل فيعني ادري
الجواب ما هو عمليه يمكن شويه
بس فعلا صار
يعني استفيد من الساعه ساعتين الواحد ممكن
يلها فيها
بشكل كبير وانا بيني وبينك يعني صار عندي
عائله الحمد لله عندي قيس رولا الحين
عيالي الله يحفظك
بس يعني انا بالنسبه لي يعني انترلي دائما
يعني احب احرس ان انا اكون يعني موجود
متاح حق حق يعني اهلي وعيالي صراحه انا
عندي هدف في السنه هذه اني احسبت المتوسط
الاستخدام الجوال وانصح اي احد ما سواها
انه يشيك على الجوال عنده يشوف متوسطه
استخدمت الجوال كم السنه الماضيه كان ثمان
ساعات في اليوم تفاجات صراحه
تستخدم الجوال بشكل متفرق على مدى اليوم
وبعدين تفاجا ثمان ساعات طارت من يومك
لمجرد انك تناظر في الجوال منها شغله
ومنها يا حزين يعني توني كنت اجازه يا
حسين يحزني لما اشوف
مثلا قاعد انت على بحر على البحر واحد
جايب ايباد مجابل الايباد بداله يجاوب
مثلا المنظر اللي قدامه منظر بالنسبه
ترى منظر مو حلو ايش قاعد يسوي يعني شنو
حياته هذا اللي عايش
ايجابيا على انتاجيتي خلال اليوم على
مزاجي وعلى
حذف التيك توك
هذا بس اشوف الربع
شغالين فيه صراحه برافو عليهم يرفع لهم
القبعه سمعت كلام ما ادري هو كلام صحيح
ولا لا بس يعني
موجود حق الصين والاطفال اللي في الصين
مختلف عن اللي موجود في العالم
مفيده
ندخل على
الجوالات
ودي نبدا معك اول شيء عن كرج تجربتك بشكل
عام فيها وتحديدا قصه الاستحواذ ما تكلمت
فيها كثير سابقا
وننهي اللقاء في كاري والمشروع جديد نفس
القطاع ونفس الفكره الاختلافات خلنا
كبدايه نبدا بسالفه 2015 صح خلاني اطلع
بفكره كرج
انا انا كنت توني داعش في حياه
وبلشت فيها كانت عندي افكار كثيره ودائما
يعني ويا الوالد رحمه الله عليها
وقتها مو وقتها حتى انا كنت ادرس بامريكا
بس اذا برجع بالشريط ورا شوي بامريكا كنت
احب اشوف وثائقيات وثائقي او جمع وثائقي
مدري شنو
وبالذات كنت احب اشوف على البحر وعن اسماك
القرش وما الى ذلك فاذكر ده شيء تقوله
بداياتها كان هولو توي طالع
وكتبت شاركس بشوف يعني
وثائقيات
القرش
فيطلع لي هالبرنامج اسمه شارك تانك حلو
وراس على اول
يعني اول فيديو طلع لي المهم واندمج فيه
وهذا اللي يتكلم وقتها كانوا يسوون خمس
مستثمرين
دولارات
اللي دش ويعرف المنتج اللي عنده ويتكلم عن
المنتج فشدني الموضوع عن الاستثمار يبحث
عن الاستثمار وحتى كنت اسولف حق مصعب
اخويا اقول لها يا اخي شوف شلون يستثمرون
يقول لي مالك
ما حد يستثمر بهالطريقه لازم فيديو
فدائما كان يشدني هالموضوع انه كيف ادش
على مستثمر واتكلم وياه ويعطيني فلوس يعني
على اساس اني ابلش المشروع كان بالنسبه لي
شيء يعني غريب المهم تم كل سنه ينزل جديد
يعني موسم جديد
وكنت كل ما اشوف فكره تعجبني اروح اقعد مع
الوالدي ايش رايك بالفكره هذي بلش فيها
نسوي كذا فكان دايم يعني يحط لي ما كان
يجاملني حط لي الثغرات قبل المساوه قبل
المحاسن فيها المهم سنه من السنين قررت لا
بخوض التجربه انا بفتح لي مطعم حالي من
حالك قبل لا تصير هبه المطاعم بشكل كبير
هالكلام 2015 فتحت المطعم شهر واحد 2015
الحين
عده مواسم شفت كل الافكار المختلفه شفت
مطعم
خلاص
يعني الهبه موجوده بس قبل لا يصير في يعني
المطاعم بالكثره هذه كنت ابي افتح مشروع
وكنت ابي اطلع من الوظيفه اللي انا فيها
كنت بالنفط شركه خاصه مليت تعبت خذيت اللي
ابي وصلت مرحله يعني صار الموضوع ينعاد
اكثر ما هو يعني شيء جديد قاعد اكتشفه
يعني قاعد يخلق لي
الدرايف اللي يخليني كل يوم اقوم واشتغل
الصبح فتحت المطعم مالك بالطويل المطعم
يعني كان بالنسبه لي راح يخليني يعني انجح
انسان في العالم
واكتشفت انه طبعا هالكلام ما هو صحيح يعني
على طول
لكن في ذلك الوقت بلشت يعني نشوف طرق ان
احنا نسوي توصيل توصيل طلبات
فالابليكيشن كان موجود التطبيق اللي كان
موجود في وقتها كان تطبيق طلبات وبنفس
الوقت هذا اسمه
الشركه اسمها طلبات
وبذاك الوقت بالذات كان توه طالع
الاستحواذ مال شركه طلبات
حتى اذكر كان في قهوه
قهوه يم المطعم عندي كنت دائما اروح اقعد
هناك فخبر كنت قاعد انا وشريكي بالمطعم
اسمع شباب ورايا شذي من اعمارنا يتكلمون
عن استحواذ طلبات باميه 160 مليون دولار
لانه في شركه من برا
استحوذت على طلبات 160 دولار بالنسبه لي
كان الموضوع يعني
مستحيل شركه بالمانيا تجي تستحوذ على شركه
بهالقيمه بصفقه بهالطريقه يعني اكيد في
شيء احنا مو شايفينه عرفت شلون وشريكي كان
يعرف احد الشركه اللي في شركه طلبات
الوقت يعني بالنسبه لي يعني ما كان
الموضوع بالنسبه لي يعني منطقي ان انت
تجيب لي الطلب وتاخذ مني مبلغ وانا اتكلم
في التوصيل طلبات كان عندكم سابقا ما يجيك
مندوب من عندهم انت اللي توصله
فقط
نسبه
ياخذ مبلغ مقطوع اللي هو نص دينار لما
يعادل تقريبا سته سبعه ريال مرتاحين
الامور طيبه كلها
فتوى يعني كانت شركه جدا رابعه ربحانه
فطبيعه الحال شركه الالمانيه شافت هذه
الشركه اللي هي شركه طلبات كانت
من اوائل الشركات في كثير من الدول من اهل
الكويت من البحرين منها الامارات منها قطر
كانت
في هذه الدول
فاستحولت عليه بالنسبه لي كان الموضوع
يعني ما هو منطقي المهم مالكم الطويله
بلشنا وياهم قمنا نشوف الطلبات تجينا عشره
عشرين ثلاثين بعض الاحيان طلب اليوم قام
حلوه
والدايمون خف شوي دائما في شهر العسل
الطلبات اللي يجون الناس يقعدون عند كل
المطعم
الموضوع يعني يحوس ببالي انه كان في في
فرصه بالموضوع فاحد بلشت الفكره شلون بلشت
الفكره انه اليوم لما الزبون يطلب في ذاك
الوقت الزبون لما كان يطلب من طلبات ما
كان في طريقه انه يعرف وين طلبه فكانوا كل
شوي يدقون علينا بالمطعم وين الطلب وين
الطلب
يدقون على طلبات لا
ما طلعوا له المطعم فكان فيها
يعني المسكه رحت حق مصعب الخوي قلت له
مصعب
عندي فكره احط اجهزه تتبع في سيارات
ولما يجي طلب من طلبات
المندوب يوصل الطلب برسل رابط حق العميل
يتبع الطلب
فكره يعني كانت يعني جدا بالنسبه لي
منظوري بدائيه جدا يعني
فالكلام 2015 فاذكر حتى اول مره كنا
قاعدين في ستاربكس اسمها النزهه عندنا
كان يقول لي حلو فمعناته لازم يسوي شيء
اسمه
اول مره اسمح الكلمه شنو
يقول لي يعني الزبون لما يطلب ينقي اقرب
سايق وبلش يشرح لي الفكره بشكل عام
فكره يعني ما يحتاج ان انا هذا فبلشت ابحث
بالموضوع من يسوي من يسوي هالخوارزميات
هذيلي
كان يقول لي انا عندي لك خوش واحد قلت له
منو كان يقول عندي صديق كان يدرس بالجامعه
في امريكا
هو بالوست يعني
بالغرب وانا بالشرق
فعندي شخص كان يدرس كمبيوتر
المهم رفع عليه التلفون كان يقول عندنا
الفكره واحد اثنين ثلاثه
لحظه هذا الشيء موجود في امريكا اسمه بعرف
ايش في شركات يعني كانت موجوده ولا لا
تخيلنا مو موجود بالكويت تخيلنا هذا شيء
جديد في تعطش كبير مطاعم كثيره ما توصل
لانه ما تبي تستثمر في هذا بلشنا شنو
نحاول نبيع الفكره
وقتها وهو كان عنده علاقه اللي هو
التقرير التعليم اي تقنيه التعليم
والله ممتاز والله ما شاء الله عليك
شلون كنا نحاول ننقنعه انه يبطل هالموضوع
وهينا الخليج
كان يقول ها انا عندي شخص ممكن اخليه يدير
الشركه خليه يجيكم نتكلم بالموضوع المهم
يعطيك طياره
وصل الكويت قعدنا وياه طبعا وقتها كنا
قاعدين في مكتبي اللي فوق المطعم المكتب
يمكن 15 متر مربع عباره عن مخزن حق الاكل
الفائض من هذا بثلاجات وفريزرات وكذي
والجزء الثاني عباره عن مكتب صغير حاطين
في طاولتين وكنت موظف اول موظف اوبريشنز
مانجر شغالين فيه فكنا احنا انا ولو
اخوي وهذا شريكنا اللي جاي الامريكي اللي
على اساس كنا بنقابل الفتره المهم ويقتنع
كيف افتح موقع المطعمين مشينا عندي لك رقم
اقوى مبرمج في السعوديه بعطيك اياه
[موسيقى]
من جدك الحين تقدر تخلص وتسوي موقع وتضيف
المنيو كامل عن طريق
[موسيقى]
بالك من عملات التوصيل وخل عملائك اقرب لك
مع موقع تطبيق
نقسم الكيكه قلنا عبد الله طلع بالفكره
هاك النسبه
انت يا جون هالنسبه ومصعب هالنسبه
فتغدوا مصعب
الحين
قسمناهم بطريقه انه يعني صراحه ما اذكر
الارقام بالضبط بس خذيت انا نسبه اعلى
بحكم ان انا كنت ادير والفكره جت مني
[موسيقى]
انت يا جون وانت يا مصعب نسبهم كانت نفس
الشيء
[موسيقى]
الموقع سيء كله اعلانات
والسيء للغايه حتى خبر يعني يقول لي لا
كنا عادي ما في شيء قلت له لا يبغى في شيء
في مشاكل ايه قلت له في مشاكل في هذا احس
انه نقدر نسوي كذا المهم اقتنع ريان اقتنع
فهني ردينا قسمنا الكيكه كلمت مصعب ابو
جون قلت لهم يا جماعه ترى انا بدخل شريك
رابع وهذا الشريك الرابع راح يكون اساسي
انه انا وياه تعاون ان نقدر يعني نقسم
الشغل بيننا ونعرف يعني شلون نرتب الامور
فردينا قسمنا الكيكه مره ثانيه خذينا من
نسبتي وخذينا من نسبه مصعب من نسبه جون
وعطينا
او هو كان بيسك لي سي او كان مدير تشغيل
مدير تشغيلي وانا كنت
التنفيذي والسيتي اللي هو مدير تقنيه
التنفيذي
وبس بلشنا انطلقنا اتكلم معارفه تكلمت
معارفي يا معنى 15 مطعم على اساس انه نوقع
وياهم حلو
فخلال هالفتره كانت شغله جون انه هو يبلش
بالابلكيشن بالتطبيق الخوارزميات اللي
تكلمنا عنها بالاساس
المهم يوميا وقت التاسيس
طبعا هالكلام في 2015 يعني مع انه مو وقت
من زمان يمكن ست سبع ثمان سنين يعني لكن
تكلم يعني في في التطور اللي صار بهالفتره
هذه تكلم كانها ثلاثين سنه هنا بنروح
بنسجل بغرفه تجاره ان هذه الشركه موجوده
طبعا وقتها ما نفهم انه في شيء اسمه
الكويت والقصه هذي كلها شو مسوين رايحين
غرفه تجاره منسجل النسب
بالرخصة نفسه هذا عشان اشرح
شركه برا الكويت هي لشركه تقسموا فيها
النسب تكون فيها مرونه اعلى
وتتحكمون في ابناء نظام الدولي تدفع فيها
مرونه كبيره تنموه تكبر وتكون الشركه هذه
اللي تملك الشركه المحليه
فكانت النسب فيها فواصل
33.3
اربعين فاصله خمسه فرحنا غرفه تجاره الحين
بنسجل نسب دشينا عليهم احنا الاربعه يا
جماعه النسب على اثنين ثلاثه شو يقول لي
لا
السيستم ما يقبل الفواصل قلت له شلون يعني
ما شو اسمه الحين يعني الحمد لله ان ما
يفهم عربي لان شلون بوصل له مسج انه احنا
عندنا السيستم فقط يقبل رقمين ما يقبل
ثلاث ارقام
فحاولنا نشرح لها بطريقه معينه ابد
نسبتي اخذها النظام الامريكي ويعني مفهوم
يعني الموضوع لانه متعود على طريقه معينه
انت جاي تبي قناه طريقه اخرى ما راح
يستوعب الفكره ولا راح يستوعب في واحد
فيكم بيخسر نص ولا بيخسر في واحد يعني
بياكلها فقلنا انا اتنازل اخذ نسبه كامله
ونسوي عقود خارجيه تحكم العلاقه تحكم
العلاقه اول شيء من ناحيه ان ان كل واحد
له نسبته صحيحه وتحكم العلاقه من ناحيه
انه احنا احنا اربع شركة واحد فينا قرر
فجاه انه ما بيشتغل ياخذ نسبه ويمشي يصير
فسوينا شيء معروف يسمونه
اللي هو تاخذ نسبتك حسب مده زمنيه معينه
تكون موجوده تكون موزعه على مثلا اربع
سنين ثلاث سنين كل شهر تاخذ نسبه من نسبتك
الكامله خلال اربع سنين تكمل نسبتك
الكامله فهذا شيء هما كان موجود بطبيعه
الحال ما عندهم فواصل بس بعدها اسسته
الشركه بره ورتبت الامور هذي كلها
شهر كامل ما كان قاعد يسوي الابلكيشن ما
كان قاعد يطور فكنا احنا في مرحله انه
نبلش التطبيق ولا نقفل الموضوع خلاص نقول
حق المطاعم احنا اسفين ما راح نقدر نسوي
الفكره المهم نختصر الموضوع حلينا الازمه
قدرنا ان احنا نسوي التطبيق انطلقنا بشهر
اربعه 2015
وبلشنا الحمد لله كانت البدايات جدا
متواضعه بلشنا اول شهر كنا نسوي بشهر خمسه
يعني
200 طلب باليوم
والمطاعم اللي كانت موجوده عندنا ولا فيها
ولا واحده في ولا واحده فيهم كانوا يوصلون
يعني كانت القيمه المضافه عندنا حق المطعم
انه تعال انت لا تستثمر تفليت احنا نوصل
لك ونموذج عملك النسبه ولا رسوم طبعا تعال
اقنع هم انه في نسبه كان هذا شيء بالنسبه
لهم مو منطقي كانك بتدش شريك وياي
لان تكلفه التوصيل عاليه جدا عرفت شلون
فلابد ان انت تخليها نسبه من القيمه
الكامله طلب كبير
من الطلب كان في دليفري فيه على العميل
ثاني شهر شفنا في نمو اسرع واكبر هذا
الشهر الرابع شهر الخامس شهر بلش الاسم
يطلع شك الاكبر هني كنا فقط في الكويت
سادس شهر جاني تليفون من من شركه
راس مال جريء بي سي في السعوديه امن اوائل
اللي كانت موجوده السلام عليكم وياك فلان
الفلاني كان بالنسبه لي موضوع غريب يعني
ايش عرفك
يعني احنا راس مال جاريه نستثمر في شركات
حابين نسمع عنكم شنو اللي عندكم قلت له
والله الساعه المباركه بالعكس شنو يعني
انا ما ادري شو السالفه يعني شنو تبون
تسمعون شنو تبون تعرفون حياك عندنا في
الشرقيه نبي نقعد وياكم
المهم بنفس الوقت كان عندي طبعا ما ادري
فيه ولا اعرف استخدمه ولا هذا بس كنت ادش
من وقت لوقتها كان يوصلني بالايميل طلب
انه اضافات وما الى ذلك ولا اشوف في واحد
مرسل لي مسج
المسج انا فلان الفلاني من شركه دليفري
هيرو
سمعنا عنكم ودي اخذ وياك تليفون
هذا المسج وصلني بشهر 12
انا شفت المسج قلت شلخر سبام هذا يعني
معقوله الدلفري هيرو اللي
شربوني اشكال وهم قبلها كانوا الربع يسوون
بريطانيا
كلمني بلهجه بريطانيه يقول لي
عرفت اللي يعني شيء على شيء حسيت انه كانه
هيك يعني الموضوع كانه واحد يعني قاعد
يسوي دقه
فحجرت المسج والله واركب السياره انا
باخوي
تقريبا يمكن
[موسيقى]
الطرف باليوم تقريبا هالمحاري فقط في
الكويت وكنا وقتها قاعد اسس انه ببلش
بالبحرين ليش قررت انه بالبحرين لاني قلت
ما راحت السعوديه اول شيء السعوديه كبيره
ما عندي فلوس خلها ادش البحرين مركز صغير
ومنها دش الشرقيه واتوسع من الشرقيه الى
الرياض وغيره بحكم ان هم الكويت قريبه من
الشرقيه فيسمعونها
شركات ياخذون يروحون للبحرين بالاضافه
لانه سوق يعتبر صغير يعني تخبيص ممكن يكون
في يحتوون الموضوع بسهوله مقارنه باسواق
اكبر
يا اخوانك تجربه اولى جيده للتوسع الدولي
كيف يقدرون دوله ثانيه الاختلافات في
العمله الانظمه والامور كلها ياخذون
النموذج هذا اللي بناه وعممونه على دول
ثانيه 100% واللي نظفتها المدير العام
هناك كان اول موظف خارج في الكويت
كان يعني هذه كانت
الى انه ترى انت بتبلش بالبحرين لكن ابيك
تمسك السعوديه تعلم البحرين اغلط بالبحرين
خبص بالبحرين على قولتك لكن تعال
بالسعوديه لا ابيك يعني تبيضها
[موسيقى]
فالمهم مسكنا الخط السياره راحين لهذا طول
الدرب واحنا كان تدرب على وش وشلون نتكلم
ويا
الشركه هذه المستثمر وندش ونقعد طبعا طول
الدرب انا تلفوني ساينا
وندش على المستثمر ونتكلم
ويعطينا يعني الجو اللي هو يعني
كانه مو وايد اترست
خيره ربي لك الحمد اكيد في شركات ثانيه
عندها اهتمام ان احنا ممكن نكلمه بالكويت
هذا فتح الباب وحلو ان احنا عندنا
الماتيريال يلا خلنا نرجع الكويت ونبلش
تدريب بعد هذه اعرف شنو الاسئله شنو
المتطلبات المهم واحنا رادين ان شاء الله
طلع تلفوني ولا داق علي رايه بالخير
مال شركه طلبات اللي باع على دليفري سلام
عليكم وعليكم السلام
ترى كلموني يا جماعه الدليفري هيرو وعندهم
اهتمام يسمعون منك
هذه الضربه اللي بتجينا ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله سكر تليفون وسراخ بالسياره ما
شاء الله شلون ما شلون يعني
المهم ردينا الكويت قعدنا ويا الوالد يبان
موضوعها اثنين ثلاث وفيه اهتمام في هذا ما
شاء الله الله يبارك ما يتدخل طبعا انا
شلون يعني شلون قدرنا نبلش ويريست يعني
دخلنا راس مال قيمه صغيره مبلغ مليون و300
دولار دولار
هذا كان السيد
300 كان عباره عن اربع مستثمرين
الوالد الله يرحمها عمي ولد عمي وصديقي
فيا معنى هالمبلغ وقلنا بنبلش فيه لان ربي
لك الحمد كانت الارقام وايد زينه بالبدايه
ما كنا مضطرين ان احنا نزيد راس المال
عرفت شلون لكن
يعني السبب اللي احنا رحنا ويا المستثمر
السعودي كانت نحنا نبي نتوسع بطريقه اسرع
فكنا نبي نتوسع بشكل اسرع المهم ردينا
الكويت بلشنا نتكلم ويا كذا شركه ثانيه
وبنفس الوقت بلش موضوع دليفري هيرو ها
يتحرك شوي يعني ودي ادخل بتفاصيل اكثر
شلون يتحرك بعد
عقب اول مكالمه
دق علي
خلني اعطيك الايميل
الشخص هذا اللي هو مسؤول المرجره
وياك فلان الفلاني
نبي نقعد وياك قلت له تمام
اول طبعا قبل لا نقعد وياك صار في
تليفونات السلام عليكم طبعا يعني صار في
تليفون ان منو انت وش قاعد تسوون شنو
فكرتكم شنو هذا اكيد هم كان عندهم تصور بس
كانوا يحاولون ان هم يعني يلقطون اكثر
معلومات اكثر
بعدها بلشنا اقول لك نتكلم ويا مستثمرين
ثانيين على اساس انه مثل ما يقولون ما تحط
البيضه كل بيضاتك بسله واحده توزعهم
فاتكلمني وشركه استثماريه تكلمنا وياه
شركات راس مال جريء ثانيه تكلمنا يعني
شخص
شخص يعني هامور احنا نسميه بالكويت اللي
يبليه
عنده اهتمام ان ان النبي
يستثمر بالشركه نفسها فكان في كذا محادثه
قاعد تصير بنفس الوقت لكن انا بالنسبه لي
كانت اهم محادثه محادثه دليفري هير عرفت
شلون زيكم
بنفس السرعه مثلا او واحد ثالث يدخل معاكم
شوف كان اول اول شيء مسوينا احنا كان كنا
يعني
حرسنا ان احنا يكون عندنا مثل
شو القصور قبل يحفرون في نهر القصر
يعني
يكون صعب الاستنساخ شلون سوينا الخنادق
قلنا نوقع المطاعم حصري المطعم اللي يدش
وياي ما تدش في مكان ثاني عرفت شلون مسموح
بعدين اليوم شركات وحاولوا يقلدون ما
قدروا يقلدون فبلشوا يتجهون انهما
يشتكون في في جهاز حمايه المنافسه وغيره
اوكي
نقفل على المطاعم تبي تدش وياي حياك الله
انا عندي
عندي السواقين عندي السواقين عندي
انا بالمليون طبعا هذا اقوى قرار خذيته في
حياتي لليوم انه شلون بهالجره كنت رحت
خذيت لي خمسين دباب كاش والمبلغ ورحت اخذت
لي 120 سياره
يوم حتى يوم وقعت وخلاص
خمسين سياره اقساط كانت بس كانت الاقساط
يعني يسمونه مثل الرهن يعني شخصي
فكان يعني قرار يتهور جدا جدا جدا
بس وقتها الواحد يعني لا عائله
بالنسبه للقرار اسهل يتحمس يفكر فيه زي
كذا خطير جدا غلط غلط جدا
فحتى اذكر يوم يوم شرينا ال 50 دباب كانوا
حاطين من هوندا كانوا حاطين تحت بالكراج
عشان يدق علي عشان يقول لي ترى ذهبين
وانزل تحت
وصور الدبابات يعني حتى كان منظر بالنسبه
لي في رهبه شوي ايش بسوي فيهم
بس قلت خلاص فيك فيك الموضوع يعني انت
تكلفت ودفعت تحمل مسؤوليه يعني جبت العمال
والدبابات والسيارات صرت توصل باسطولك
فكنا ايه فكنا حتى السواقين ما كانوا
موجودين فكنا ننزل صوب بالكويت صوب السوق
وين يتجمعون الجاليات هذيل الكنيسه
المعروف ايش هذا فكنا دائما نروح هناك
ندورهم ندورهم يوم الاحد بالذات
فنروح نقعد عند هذا تعالي تبي تشتغل سايق
تبي تشتغل ايش رايك ان انا اشغلك تعال شوف
كنت حاطه عارض عندي بالمكتب هذا ابو 15
متر حاط سيكل
النص على اساس اني اوري للجماعه اني اشوف
الدباب مرتبتي هوندا 160 سي سي يعني مو
شغل الدبابات اللي كلام فكانوا يتحمسون
شلون تظن انه ما ينسرق اذا جاك واحد من
الشارع
انا صاد
المكتب وقصدي
الدبابات اللي تعطيها للعمال عشان يوصلون
والله صارت
في المكتب
والله صارت مواقف للامانه يعني كنا عادي
مثلا فجاه يختفي الدباب ولا السياره تختفي
شهر شهرين نلقاها بالمطار ساقطه ولا
نلقاها هذا بس احد الشغلات اللي كنت
اسويها بالبدايه اقول حق السائق تعال دش
وياي اذا تميت وياي سنتين اخذ الدباب عليك
بالعافيه عرفت شلون فانت في بالك يعني
ممكن انه وايد ناس اخذوا الدبابات
وبالاخير ثلاثه من اصل 50
اللي هي الاسطوره التوصيل الخاص فيك وايضا
الحصريات اللي كنت تقفل على المطاعم فيها
فهذا اعطاك افضليه اذا كان غير طلبات فقط
خلي المستثمرين والدليفري ومتعطشين انهم
يتعاملوا
هني نتكلم اقول لك في مستثمرين كثار بلشنا
انه يصير فيها بلشنا احنا نفتح
شركات ثانيه فتحت فيها
يعني محادثه ويا شركه معروفه هنا بالخليج
تبع
التوصيل التكاسي توصيل البشر يعني
قالوا لكم الموضوع استحواذ الدليفري هيرو
كان الموضوع بالنسبه لهم كانه تفقد يبي
يشوف انت منو
فيه اهتمام اننا نسمع منكم طبيعه الحال
شنو يعني يعني ان في انترسنا ممكن يكون في
استحواذ
المهم اول اجتماع كان وياهم كان في لندن
هذا نفس الشخص مع شخص ثاني
كانوا مستحودين على شركته اصبح بالبورد
عندهم
كان يعني هذا اول اجتماع يصير فيه كشف بعض
الارقام
ونظره الشخص حق حق يعني حقنا احنا كانت ان
انت خليجيين يعني ما ابي ما ابي يعني
اقولها بطريقه نقول بطريقه شوي اكثر يعني
احنا احسن منكم
فكانت نظره ما هي
فوقيه ايه فيها فوقيه كانه يعني انا متفضل
عليكم
وبعدها يعني قمنا نهتم في
المحادثات الثانيه اكثر يوم من الايام رفع
التلفون عشان يقول عندي لكم اثر هذا نفس
الشخص
شنو الاوفر عشان يقول الاوفر ابي اعطيكم
نبي نستحوذ على الشركه بقيمه 80 مليون
بالكامل بالكامل ثمانين مليون دولار لكن
كله اسهم في دليفري وقتها كانت شركه ما هي
مدرجه
وشركه يعني
اندهن نشاطات خلينا نقول ما هي شريعه يعني
ما هي متوافقه مع الشريعه
فكان عندنا بعض التحفظات على هذا الموضوع
عشان يقول وانا بتفضل عليكم بالثمانين انه
فعليا لما تجي تشوف الرسك لما تشوف
المخاطره في السوق الخليجي في مخاطره
كبيره المفروض اعطيكم 60 لكن هاكم
الثمانين
فقلنا له لما يصير عندك اثر زين اتصل
علينا شكرا بامان الله سكينا التليفون
كان مثل
الجانب الشريعي فقط كما عجبنا المبلغ ما
عاجبنا انه كله ستوك ما عجبنا توك بادلك
سنه ما عجبني
له سنه بس شفنا
الاقبال من من الكل والجميع تدري شي
اليسار خطا طيبه كثار
بعينك اكثر
فقلنا له اصلا احنا عندنا ناس مهتمين
غيركم شكرا في امان الله سكرنا التليفون
[موسيقى]
مليون كاش يبي يستثمر واحد ب 100 مليون
استثمارات هذا الوحيد اللي كان استحواذ
المهم
يعني
احنا كنا حريصين انه ما نتشتت بعد يعني
لان كنا اربع شركاء فكان عندنا شركه
مركزين على البزنس انا مصعب كنا مركزين
على الاستحواذ فكان في هل هل
تفرع وهذا الزين لما يكون عندك يعني شرك
اكثر انه متفاهمين ان كل واحد يقدر يركز
على شيء معين
وقتها هم كان يصير وايد في بيار يعني
اثناء شركه الجزيره سوينا وثائق وياهم
العربيه جتنا يعني شوي كبر راسنا مثل ما
يقولون
وهم وقتك كنا قاعد نبلش نتوسع بالبحرين
وظفت ابو عزيز الله يرحمه وخلاص بلشنا ان
احنا نشتغل بالبحرين
المهم فجاه بيوم وليله يرفعوا علينا
التلفون عشان يقولون يا جماعه احنا مهتمين
وبس نبي نسالكم هل في ناس ثانيه قاعد تنظر
لكم في موضوع الاستحواذ
فقلنا لهم اي في مستثمرين ثانيين قاعد
ينظرون والتقييم اكثر من تقييم اللي انت
قلت اياه ماكو يومين
راكبين الطياره واصلين الكويت فريق الكامل
مال فريق الاستحواذ
صار في حاجهم هالفومه هذا الفيروس تفوتهم
تخاف تفوتهم عرفت شلون المهم وصلوا الكويت
اقعدوا
ويانا فتحنا لهم كتبنا اعطيناهم الارقام
اعطيناهم كل شيء
وكان يعني كانت فتره جدا
[موسيقى]
في ضغط ضغط عالي
لان ارقام نبي نطلعها
يعني اكثر باكثر شكل دقيق ما كان عندنا
ارقام
موثقه من شركات خارجيه فكنا يعني كلنا
يعني قاعد نحاول نحرص ان احنا نوفر لهم
الارقام لانه بنسكر الموضوع باسرع وقت
ويانا ضغط ثاني اللي جاينا هذا مال
الاستحواذ يا جماعه
ترى انا فقط عندي خمس ايام ان اخلص الديل
لان بعدها الخمسه ايام اذا ما وقعنا شركه
دليفري هيرو راح تندرج بالبورصه ففيها
الفتره الزمنيه بين الفتره هذه لين تندرج
بالبورصه هذي فتره التقشف هذه ما المفروض
يكون في اي حركه من ناحيه استحواذات وغيره
لان التقييم يكون ثابت ليه يسمونه
بل هذا فيا انه خلص بهالوقت
نضطر انه ناجل لايتالي وما تدري ايش يصير
تالي لما
رمضان بعد المهم كنت مكملين من تاسيس
الشركه هذه وقتها تممنا سنه توه حلو
الكلام كم شهر خمسه
2017 حلو
فهني اللي اتفقنا على المبالغ هنا اللي
اتفقنا على كل شيء شافوا رقم معين هذا رقم
كان بالنسبه لهم يعني
ممتاز اللي هو يعني صراحه ما اعرف اسمه
بالضبط بالعربي بس يسمونه
اللي هو لما تشوف العميل اللي يطرب يطلب
اول مره باول شهر كم مره يرد يطلب خلال
فتره زمنيه
فهذا الرقم بس هو يعني بشكل عام بشرحه
حفاظكم على عملاء كان يعني ممتاز جدا بدون
ما
يدخلني بس يعني هذا رقم كان بالنسبه لهم
جدا مهم وهذا اللي اكبر انه العملاء يتكرر
نفس العملاء يرجعون يطلبون منكم يعني
العميل لما يدش لما تستحوذ عليه بمبلغ
معين استحوذ عليه قاعد يطلب منك بشكل
مستمر حق فتره زمنيه معينه
عرفت شلون وهذا بالنسبه لهم هذا الرقم ما
شافوه ولا تطبيق ثاني ومستحوذوا عليه هم
يشوفون العملاء اللي بداوا يطلبوا من
عندكم في يناير نسبه كبيره منهم ما زالوا
مستمرين معكم الى مثلا ديسمبر نفس الشيء
من فبراير
والغريب بالنسبه لهم انه مو فقط كانوا
قاعد يردون يطلبون كانت قاعد تزيد الطلبات
بلوتهم مع الوقت فمتوسط طلباتهم قاعد
يرتفع فهذا بالنسبه لهم اصلا يعني
بالبدايه يوم شافوا الرقم هذا قالوا اكيد
في غلط بالارقام
لكن كانوا جايبين الشخص المسؤول عندهم
على هالكلام هذا
ربي لك الحمد تمت الامور بسلام قبل ما تتم
بسلام كم كم عرضوا عليكم اخر شيء فعرضوا
علينا 180 مليون على اساس قيمتها قيمناها
معين على مضاعفات معينه على
الليرات
فارادنا كان مبلغ
وضاعفوه حسب التوسع اللي ممكن يكون لانه
اول اقتراح لهم ولا كان في جدل على كيف
تقيمون الشركه طبعا
80 مليون قلنا لهم لا بعدين قالوا لنا راح
نعطيكم اياه
بس ليش كنت راسهم بس عشان الجانب الشريف
الشرعي بشكل كبير وجانب ثاني تبي الكاش
يعني اكيد
ما تدرين
يعني شنو الايراد اللي ممكن هيك منه
واذا كنت شايف النمو الكبير بهالدرجه ليش
قيمتها مليار مثلا والله سؤال ممتاز لكن
انت شيء انت شاب توك توك طالع من وظيفه
اياك شخص دندلك هالشيك بها القيمه كلها
كاش يعني صعب انه انت تتخيل انه هي ممكن
توصل للمواصيل هذه فوق هذا كله كان في
المخاطره مالت ان انت كنت وقتها فقط
بالكويت فكانت فيها المخاطره
في السعوديه في البحرين في قطر في
الامارات ولا لا ولا هو شيء فقط في الكويت
فكان في مخاطره كبيره
يعني ما اقول لك ان انا ما كنت مستعد أخوض
فيها لكن كان بالنسبه لي الجانب اللي انا
عصفور باليد وايد افضل من ان انا في طريق
غلط
تقريبا كل او اغلب الناس اللي مره مروا
علي من اصحاب الشركات اللي جتهم عروض
بهالغراء بسرعه غالبا هالشيء يعزز عندهم
شعور انه يتمسكهم اللي انا بمسك اوكي اذا
في اهتمام كبير لهالدرجه شكله اقدر اوصلها
500 اوصلها للمليار بس طبعا ما في شيء غلط
يعني في ناس مثل ما سويت
الفرصه موجوده بروح اشوف ايش سويت فيها
وافقوا على موضوع انه تكون كاش
واحنا يعني وقتها كان بالنسبه لنا يعني
مستثمرين كانوا ويانا ناس معينه وقتها
يعني هم ما بالامور الشخصيه بس يعني
كان فيه يعني مواقف صارت يعني ايه اللي
خلتنا يعني نروح الى هالجانب هذا قبل ما
ندخل المواقف الفريق اللي جاءكم كان بيده
القرار كامل ولا كان لازم يرجع من
الاستداره طبعا
اخلص الموضوع ليش القرارات بيدهم
وكانوا ناطرين السيو مال شركه دليفري هي
بس على اساس يعني توقيع اخر شيء كان يعني
واضح انهم اعطيهم يبلشون ليش لانه كانوا
بيدرجون بالبورصه فهذه الشغلات اغلب
الشركات شو تسوي قبل لا تندرج البورصه
تحاول انها تكبر تقييمها بشكل كبير بحيث
انها تستحوذ على شركه ناشئه فيها هل
[موسيقى]
كلها مستقبل كبير لا المستقبل هذا عرفت
فيصير يشترونها الشركه اضاعف يعني هو فعلا
مكشرونا 200 مليون حلو او عفوا 180 مليون
لكن
[موسيقى]
الاميه 180 مليون اللي يدفعوها فعليا
قيمتها لهم لما مليار مثلا عرفت لان السوق
يقيمهم حسب النمو اللي ممكنهما شركائك
والمستربين كلهم كانوا متفقين انه خلاص
عشرين ضعف
في غضون سنه ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
عشرين ضعف يقرون سنه يعني اللي دش انا
عندي احد المستثمرين دش بخمسين الف دينار
اللي هو ما يعادل 150 الف دولار
خذاها عشرين ضعف بسنه
ما شاء الله عرفت شلون
فكان بالنسبه للموضوع يعني لا تكلمني وكان
الصفقه لها شروط تصور كانت شروطها كانت
الشروط ان نعطيكم احنا كنا نقول لهم كنا
نقول لهم يا جماعه انا وياي مستثمرين
مساله ان انا تعطيني
يعني
اسهم وما بعرفها يعني عطني كاش خليني اطلع
مستثمرين وبعدين اتفاهم وياك تاني
فصارت ان في 90 مليون كاش حطوا لنا على
التوقيع وهذه خرجنا فيها المستثمرين
وخلصنا يعني امورنا وكذا
والتسعين الثانيه قال لنا راح نعطيكم
اياها حسب ارقام معينه
تحطونها حلو
المعينه كانت حسب الفوركس اللي كنا
معطينهم ياه حسب التصور المالي اللي
معطينهم اياه وقت
الدراسه اللي هم هذا هذه الارقام
القادمه وقالوا اذا فعلا حققتوها
كم ينقص منه لو ما حققت في في يعني في اذا
مثلا هالمبلغ توصل شديد هالمبلغ توصل
فقالوا لهم بس شرط انه نبي مبلغ تشغيلي
فوقه فحطه فوقها خمسه مليون تشغيل في
مليون دولار عرفت شلون
التوسع تبي توسع بشكل كبير برا الكويت
يعني خلاص الحين الكويت قدرنا ان احنا
نستحفظ على السوق الحين نشتغل على برا
الشرطه
معينه تكملون في كرج ولا ايه كانت فتره
لاخر 2018 به كم سنه تقريبا
كل الشركه لازم يكملون كل الشراكه
على مدى سنه ونص
فلازم مو بس تكملون لازم تكمل وتحقق الهدف
من غير ما عاش من غير شيء طبعا يعني
خذينا مبلغ ما هو صغير من
مليون اللي بالبدايه خرجنا في المستثمرين
نسبهم والباقي لنا كان عرفت شلون وما بعد
هذا كان فقط لنا ما هو قالوا لكم بدون
رواتب بدون شيء
جدا سعيدين اننا نكمل بغير رواتب داوت
بشكل كبير
وقعنا الصفقه طبعا يعني هم كانت يعني شويه
فيها ملابسات لان مستثمر اجنبي داش الكويت
شلون يعني كان فيها شويه قصه مشاكل
يعني شغلات بسيطه صارت لكن الحمد لله
قدرنا ان احنا نسمسم الامور وخلصنا الامور
مالك بالطويله
بلشنا نتوسع يعني خذينا الفلوس قلنا هذه
الخمسه مليون بنحرقها ان احنا نتوسع
بالسوق دشينا بالبحرين طبعا اول شيء سويت
يوم يوم استحوذت علينا الشركه انا كنت
بخاش هالموضوع الموظفين ما كنت قايل لهم
لان ما كنت تبي المورال يطيح مالهم الدافع
المعنويات تطيح فاليوم اللي كان بيطلع
الخبر في الجريده رحت الصبح مبكر ناديتهم
كلهم قلت لهم يا جماعه ترى عندي لكم خبر
حلو وربي لك الهامده انا استحوذ علينا وما
اعرف ايش ومسوي حفله يعني انه يعني كلنا
هذا سوينا الحفله وزعنا ثلاث اربع معاشات
على كل موظف فالكل كان يعني مستانس انه
يعني هالشي موجود واعطاهم دافع انه ما
يكملون حتى بالشركه وقلنا حق المستثمرين
الثانيين اللي كان عندهم اهتمام يا جماعه
احنا اسفين لكن يعني استحوذ علينا مشكورين
لكن ان شاء الله في المستقبل اذا صار فيه
نصيب ممكن
هذا ما كان موجود
حتى اللي كان عيونك يعني بالنسبه لا انت
حطني معاش لا تعطيني لا تعطيني اسهم وكذا
يمكن يمكن ثلاثين اربعين بكمل معك على صرف
التوسع عندي سؤال فضول ابي اعرف كيف
تجربتك كشخص
يحاولون يتصورون التجربه هذه وش كان شعورك
بعد ما جاك المبلغ حق الاستحواذ
اثر التجربه هذه على انك انت تكون شخص كما
يسور ماديا امورك جيده الحمد لله ما صور
انك انت يعني كنت جدا يعني اصلا
يمكن هذا الشيء انا ما ذكرته قبل لكن انا
كنت امشي لي معاش
وانا بكرج ما يعادل تقريبا
يعني يعادل 5000 ريال شهريا عرسيه وهذا
قبل الاستحواذ
كنت انا موظف في شركه نفطيه قبل وكنت باخذ
قسط ماخذ سياره وماخذ هذا فكانت علي
التزامات يعني كنت حتى لما اكون
تخيل ان انا شركه
يعني قبل قبل يعني ثالث ثالث رابع اسبوع
من شهر انا ما عندي فلوس اطلب من كرج كانت
يعني لحاله جدا سيئه لكن بالنسبه لك انت
اشوف
البوتانشيل مال الشركه
فكنت دائما يصير فيني عادي حتى لو معاه شي
5000 ريال شنو يعني ادري انه بالاخير أنا
راح ان شاء الله الشركه راح تحقق ارباح
فلكها ان تتخيل انه يعني صاحب شركه مو
قادر يطلب حتى مطعم من هذا وكنت دائما
افتشل ان انا اطلب من الوالده او اطلب من
الاهل ان هذا بالاخير انا يعني صاحب شركه
والوالد كان يشوفني بنظره انه يعني كبر ما
شاء الله شلون يطلبني فلوس واطلبك فلوس مو
حلوه عرفت شلون فكنت انحرج من هالموضوع
سؤال يعني
[موسيقى]
تم ايداع
ملايين بحسابك
فكان بالنسبه لي حتى اذكر كنا قاعدين عند
البانكر لانه كانت الفلوس بتشبه حساب احد
الشركه وهو يوزعها علينا فكنا قاعدين عند
بانكر وانا قاعد رفيقي صاحبي يعني خالد
ويعني ما احنا قادرين نتملك هذا يعني كان
نضحك بستيريا يعني كان الوضع انه شعور
غريب انه فجاه انت كنت موظف معاشك 5000
6000 عشره الاف ريال فجاه عندك هالمبالغ
يعني شنو شنو ممكن تسوي
بس حتى بعد ما دشت الفلوس بالحساب
تمينا مثل ما احنا يعني ماكو شي تغير ما
تستوعب ان انت ممكن انت والله مثلا تشتري
شغله الفلانيه تسوي شغله الفلانيه هالشي
ما يعني مو سويتش اللي والله انا فجاه راح
اقدر اسوي كل شيء مع الوقت
اقدر اسوي كذا اقدر اسافر يعني اقدر احط
شذي اقدر اشتريها السياره
وفي كم شغله تسويها طيب خاطرك فيها خلاص
يعني يصير انه انت يعني ما تحتاج ان
الامور الماديه ما تستهويك مثل هذا
مثلا اسال السؤال
يمكن الواحد يطريها انه في ناس كثير
يتخيلون انه هذا يمكن هو الحلقه الاخيره
هو الحلم اذا وصلوا خلاص كل
جميله حياتي يعني خلاص بتصير رائعه فعليا
على الاقل من وجهه نظري
هي فقط تطيع عنك الهموم اللي
عاده سببها نكسر فلوس بس
الاحتياجات الاساسيه والترفيه المنطقي
يبدا يتغطى خلاص ما تشيل همه بعد كذا اي
شيء بعد ذلك يعتمد على قناعتك ما له دخل
اللي بعدها المرحله يعتمد هلا معك
عشره الاف500 الف ولا مليون ولا عشره
مليون القناه يعني في ناس اعرفهم يعني
بدون مبالغه جتهم مبال كبيره 20 مليون
وزعلانين يعني
اول ما تغطي احتياجاتك وترفيهك الاساس
المنطقي خلاص الموضوع انتوا قناتك يعني
مئه بالمئه شوف انا اول شيء سويتهم
وكان احلى شعور لان اول مره من توظفت ما
عندي هذه المسجد اللي تجيني تم استقطاع
المبلغتها كانت راحه نفسيه بالنسبه لي
وفوق هذا سددت بابا اعطوني مكافاني سددت
مبشر
فكان بالنسبه لي شعور راحه نفسي اني انه
خلاص يعني انا انا الحين انا في قناعه
مستديمه الحمد لله مستدامه
بطبيعه الحال اخذت لي سياره سافرت لي هني
هناك عرفت شلون وسعت صدري
يعني يعني بستانست بالمبلغ اللي يعني لكن
هل انا احس ان انا تغيرت حياتي بطريقه لا
انا يعني مثل ما انا اللهم انا الحمد لله
الحاله ميسوره ربي لك الحمد الله
التوسع الان بعدها دخلت البحرين السعوديه
ايه اللي حصل دشينا البحرين وسيطرنا
بالبحرين ودشينا بقطر وسيطرنا بق قطر يعني
كان احد الاسواق اللي دشيناها سنه ونص ما
دفعت ولا دينار ولا ريال تسويق
تخيل تخيل ان انا سنه ونص انا كل يوم
الطلبات تزيد بشكل مخيف اللي انا اصلا ما
عندي سواقين توصل ولا دفعت دينار تصوير
لا تسالني ما ادري شو اللي حصل هناك يعني
انا ودي اجاوبك شو اللي حصل لكن
القطريين بشكل عام عينهم وايد على الكويت
بالذات فكانوا دائما يسمعون يومياتهم كرج
الخدمه شيء مميز بلشوا وهو ما يتكلمون
بينهم وبين بعض عرفت شلون وفلان يوصل على
فلان وهما هناك يعني
دواوينهم والمجالس ملوتهم يعني معروفه
فالورده كان يعني جدا شيء كبير بالنسبه
لهم
انا اعرفك اقول لك تعال جرب اطلب من كرج
وهبلان يعرف هذا ويجرب يطلب من كرت فصار
التوسعه بهالطريقه بنفس الوقت قررنا ان
احنا ندش الشرقيه
عرفت شلون
ودشينا واستحوذنا وقتها كان حتى جاهز كان
مبلشين ودشينا بالرياض ودشينا بجده وصلنا
تقريبا بالسعوديه لاخر 2018 وصلنا تقريبا
19 طلب اليوم
بالسعوديه بس كان جاهز يسوي تقريبا 6000
طلب اذاك الوقت
ولكن هنقرستيشن كان ما ادري يعني يمكن كان
في يعني بعض التخوف او التحفظ انه كاريجد
الشون ما المفروض ينافسون
نفس المالك هنقرستيشن وكرج داخل في سوق
واحد
فهذه كيف كانت تجربتها جدا
مؤسسين هنقرستيشن تذكر المشكله اللي تكلم
فيها ابراهيم جاسم اعلاميا وصار فيه مشكله
من ناحيه الشراكه بينهم وحولت يعني تطورت
المشكله بعد ذلك بس من ناحيتكم من طرف
الاخر وش كان يصير انا بالنسبه لي كان
عندي ارقام لازم اعطيك
هل كان في طريقك انت تقدر تستفيد منها من
تجربه داخليا من خلال دلبري هيرو ابدا ما
كان في اي نقل اي نوع من نقل معلومات كان
في تشايني العظيم بينها وبينهم وبين اي
شركه ثانيه واحنا كنا بانيين هالسو مو
والسبب انه انت قاعد تقول لي لازم في
ارقام معينه لازم اوصلها ما يصير انت
تحبني بطريقه معينه ما يصير انت تقول لي
تعال اعطى ارقامك طلبات ولا اعط مطاعمك
طلبات ولا ما يصير
انت قاعد تقول لي في عندك الارقام تبيني
اوصلها خلني انا بريحيه اوصلها بس كيف
تقدر تضمن تشتغل وانت مرتاح وانت عارف
انهم يملكون مهما كانوا يعني كانت شركه
ناشئه بذاك الوقت وقت يعني بشكل كبير يعني
ما كان في الاستراكتشر او ما كان فيه
الاساس اللي يسمح لهم انهما
الارقام وتصير معلومات تصير منتشره بينهم
وبين الشركات الثانيه كنت اتنافس شركاتهم
في كل الاسواق صحيح
لكن ما قدرناه هو يعني يسيطر في البحرين
ويعني بغض النظر عن هنقرستيشن وهو يعني
شغل الشاغل كان ما هو مجامله ولا ايا كان
ان انا ابي اوصل الارقام وانا كاش اوت
بالاخير فحتى ما صرحت بس ما كان في تخوف
انه هذول من مصلحتهم انك ما تحقق ارقام
عشان تقل قيمه الاستحواذ
تعاقديا احنا كنا حاكرينهم تعاقديا كان
الموضوع وايد واضح انت مالك شغل ولا شيء
اسوي
عرفت شلون خلني انا انا مو افهم مو انا
اعرف السوق خلاص خلني انا اسوي اللي عليه
وحاسبني اذا انا ما حصلت الارقام بس قصدي
هو لانه يملك منافسينك
نظريا طبعا من مصلحته انك ما تحقق
الاهدافك عشان تقل قيمه الاستحواذ فكان
ممكن انه يسرب معلومات
ما حسيت انه كان في ما حسيت انه كان في
للامانه اي نوع من هذا كانت دائما تكون في
يعني انا الامانه تجربتي الشخصيه وياهم
كانت تجربه ما هي كانت تجربه زينه ما كانت
تجربه سيئه في ناس عندهم يعني راي مختلف
بهالموضوع ناس يعني كانوا قد كلمتهم
اعطونا اللي اللي اتفقنا احنا وياهم
احنا قبل لا نحقق الاهداف من هذا اللي حصل
قبل ان نحقق الاهداف قعدنا ويا الجماعه
قلنا لهم يا جماعه احنا بالفتره هذي اللي
هي تقريبا ما بعد الاستحواذ ست سبعه اشهر
انا حققت تقريبا ضعف الاهداف اللي قلت لك
انا احققها بنفس الوقت فاذا انا كنت قايل
لك انه مثلا على سبيل المثال بسوي 30 الف
طلب باليوم
6 اشهر لي قدام انا الحين مسوي مثلا 50
الف طلب
ايش رايك نتفق انا وياك
[موسيقى]
انا بس كنت ابي اخذ الفلوس اضمن الفلوس
واتم وياهم استمر وياهم
الحين اقل
وتالي أمسك شيء بيدي
والله كان في يعني
التفاوضات بيننا وبينهم وبعدين يا سي مره
ثانيه وقعدنا وياه وشرحنا له الموضوع
اقتنع بالاخير واعطانا اللي احنا نبيه
ونمينا الشركه من فتره الاستحواذ كنا نسوي
ارباح
يعني كل شيء مكتوب انه يخلي الكاش معاه
المنطق في الموضوع هذا اللي تخليه يصف
كاشف المنطق كان انه اول شيء مكانه وتوهم
داشين يعني
في السوق فكان عندهم فائض كاش بشكل كبير
عرفت شلون فوق هذا كان بالنسبه له وهو
خلاص يعني يبي هذه صفحه طويل عرفت يعني ما
كان يبي
يفكر ها لحظه ممكن المبلغ ياخذونه كامل او
ممكن ياخذونه اقل واي مبلغ ممكن يوفره
يستفيدوا منه بالاخير يعني عرفت شلون
بس في نهايه اخر كم شهر تطيح
دائما فيها
بالبزنس بشكل عام فقدرنا ان احنا نقنعها
الحمد لله وقدرنا ان احنا نوصل له المسج
ووريناه بالارقام هل هو شافها مثلا
خلني اخذ المخاطره مقابل انه يوفرها
للعشره مليون زياده بالضبط هذا اللي
بالضبط حصل انا خلني اوفر الشركه ماشيه
وعطيناهم شنو هذا هني اللي كان هذا قلنا
له عطني الفلوس وانت الحين انا مو خذيت
حقي كامل انا راح اكشف لي اكشف كتبي حق
طلبات
انت مو كان دائما شنو كانت بالفتره هذي
كانت دائما يحاولون يضغطون علينا اعطوا
طلبات المطاعم مالتكم خليكم في توافق
بينكم وبينهم انا كنت اقول لا لا لا لا لا
لا لا
هذا الجدار فهدينا الجدار عقب ما استلمنا
الفلوس
فتقابلنا وياهم بدبي
وسلمنا عليهم صار في الهان شيك وصار في
هالامور وقلنا خلاص يبقى من يوم ورايح
احنا وياكم احنا اسمين مختلفين لكن احنا
فعليا شركه واحده وراح نتعاون في امور
كثيره راح نتعاون في البطاقه راح نتعاون
في النسب راح نتعاون راح نعرض على المطاعم
يدشون وياكم
فهذا كان فنقول الاخذ والعطاء اللي صار
بيننا وبينهم اللي اللي سمح انه يعطينا
المبلغ نبشر نوع حلو يمكن
اكبر معك طلبات وطلبات كانوا اكبر منكم
ولا
بالفتره هذي كنا احنا وطلبات
نصف النص السوق بالكويت بس كانوا مثلا
كورونا بالامارات كانوا اكبر بالبحرين
ضفناهم بقطر كنا بنطوفهم وبالسعوديه ما
كانوا يعني كانوا موجودين لكن اختفوا
بس بالامارات كانوا وايد كانوا يعني
نمبر وان بالسوق الاماراتي
ففتحنا كتبنا واشتركنا وتشاورنا بيننا
وبينهم وصار فيها هذا
وتمينا لاخر وكمل في الكويت طلباتك
تميت لاخر 2018 خلص العقد بيني وبينهم
عشان يقول لي
سي او عندهم ايش رايك تجدد ويانا اعطوني
اوفر جدا يعني كريم
بالنسبه لهم اسمح لي انا يعني ما بعت ما
كنت بنور على اساس اني اكون موظف مره
ثانيه شكرا
في امان الله في امان الله وشركائك
الباقين كلنا طلعنا اربعتنا طلعنا
تم وياهم
والله حاولوا يعني
كان هذا شرط من شروط
دربي فاللي حصل انه انه خلال هالسته اشهر
صار
فيلت الاداره شوي في كارج
يابا وكذا رئيس تنفيذي شالوا وكذا
يستنفيذي صار في توظيف ناس ما ما هذا فصار
فيه شوي تخلخل بالاداره قرروا انه ياخذون
قرار انهما
يسكرون الشركه بالكامل مو يسكرونها
يدمجونها بعد طلبات فاذكروا الفتره هذه
الكرج بدا يموت في السعوديه كنت طلبات
صارت حتى طلبات ما كانت كبيره يعني ركزوا
على هنقرستيشن بشكل اساسي وفي الكويت صار
طلبات فصاروا لاعب واحد صار في
فدقيت حتى اذكر على السي او هناك رئيس
تنفيذ العمليات فيه قلت له لا لا تسوون لا
تاخذون هالقرار ما عندي مشكله ارجع حتى ما
ابي فلوس بس لا تقتلون البراند حرام
قوي
وفيها
الشعور العاطفي يعني تضايقت انهم يعني
لانه كان كان يعني كان يعني
لا سمعه بالسوق عرفت شلون كان الناس عرفت
كرج عرفت انه يعني هو اللي اسس
انك مسرعه
انا دائما اقول يعني
كانت في طور النمو بعدين استحوذوا علينا
بعدين صار في
الواحد يخليها كانها شركه
الحوكمه فمريت فيها التجارب بس يعني بشكل
كبير يعني كانت مضغوطه بشكل كبير كانت خوش
تجربه يعني
قال لي لا خلاص خذينا القرار وما راح
موضوع الاشتراكات صحيح اشترك واطلب زي ما
تبي بدون رسوم توصيل بس قفلته واشوف الحين
الناس ما شاء الله
تجربه ممتازه الامانه احنا كانت عندنا
قيمه التوصيل في الكويت دينار ما يعادل 12
ريال وفي السعوديه كانت عشره ريال وكان
يعني كله دار يعني الدينار 12 ريال
الدينار يعني كان تقريبا
هذا مال الدليفري فاحد الشغلات اللي كنا
نشوفك كنا دائما لما نسوي اوفر انه توصيل
ببلاش
يعني مجاني تطلع الطلبات بطبيعه الحال
فقلنا شلون ممكن ان احنا نحفز الناس انه
لما تدش
تطلب تطلب ما تفكر انك تطلب من اماكن
ثانيه شلون نقدر نحكرهم اكثر وشلون نقدر
ان احنا نسويها بطريقه بحيث ان احنا ما
شهريا وتقدر تطلب قلمه
واكتشفنا انه كانت يعني ضربه معلم
كانت يعني ضربه جدا موفقه ليش لانه كنا
اشتراكات النوادي الحين نادي لما يسوي
اشتراكات بشكل عام
يعني اللي يقدر المشتركين اللي يقدر اي
وقت يكون موجوده خلينا نقول مثلا الف وهو
يشرك عشره الاف
ويعول على انه 9000 ما يجونا هذول اللي
يحسون بالذنب يشتركون
يتحمس يومين الثالث خلاص بس لو جو كل احد
صمله
نفس الشيء
الفكره كانت شنو صح انت عندك مثلا
اللي يدش النادي اللي ياكل حديد هذا 24
ساعه ثلاثه اربع مرات باليوم وعندك النوع
اللي يشترك برا وخلاص فكانت الفكره ان
احنا معولين على الناس اللي تشترك لكن ما
تطلب واللي يطلب مثلا كانت في ناس يعني
تقصرها مثل ما يقولون يعني يطلب لك مثلا
ما عندي اي قوه اراده تساعدني اني اسوي
شيء او تدفعني تسوي شيء بتدفع فلوس متعور
جيبك يعني هذا القصد يعني انت تطلب انت
قاعد تدفع عرفت شلون فهي الفكره كانت شنو
تكلفه توصيل الطلب اذا ذاك اليوم بطلب
قاروره مويه تكلفه توصيل الطلب اكبر من
قيمه قاروت المويه ولا كان في حد ادنى
يعني انت خسران فعليا على كل طلب لا وفعلا
في طلبات خسران فيها لكن لما تشوفها يعني
من ناحيه
متوسط هذا لا انت انت كانت الارقام ممتازه
انا تركت وشيء بالشيء يذكر حتى بالفتره
هذه بفتره التسكيره كان في مطاعم كثيره
حتى بالسعوديه كان عليها متطلب يعني
مديونيات من دليفري هيرو وغيره وكانت
دليفري هيرو الامانه منتظره ان انه الناس
يطالب في المديونيه بعد ما قفلت كانت
الناس يعني حطها مبلغ منتظره الناس تجي
تطالب في المديونيات لكن ما احد طالب فيها
اليوم
عندها القيم يروح
ترى هذا بعد ما انا تركت فيعني ما له
علاقه احنا بالها احنا بعنا الشركه وتركنا
واللي صار تالي مالنا علاقه
بس ما اذكر صراحه انه كان محدوده في حد
ادنى ولا نموذج العمل ماني متاكد منه ولا
ابي افتي من راسي بس كاني سمعت انه فيه
على الاقل احد الشركات انها فوق الدفع
المطعم مبلغ ثابت عشان يكون جزء من
الاشتراك او كذا صحيح الكلام الحين
انه اذا تبي تكون جزء من الاشتراك هذا
المطعم يدفع جزء من التوصيل
والفكره انه بالمبلغ اللي هم ياخذونا منك
النص الثاني عرفت شلون مثلا على سبيل
المثال بعشره ريال المطعم راح يدفع خمسه
ريال على اساس يكون جزء من فوق النسبه حق
النسبه تخيل اللي يعطيها وهذي هذي يعني
شيء يعني جدا مهم الواحد يبي ينوه عليه
اليوم لما تجي تشوف
التطبيقات هذه
فعليا فعليا اغلب المطاعم ترى خسرانه
يعني لما يجي لما يجي التطبيق وياخذ من
الزبون ياخذ من المطعم عفوا نسبه وفوق
النسبه ياخذ مثلا موضوع على كل طلب ياخذ
رسوم ثابته ياخذ موضوع انه مثلا تبي تكون
فوق يدفعك زياده ياخذ موضوع في بعض
الاحيان مثل هنقرستيشن وطلبات مساله
[موسيقى]
اللي هم يسمونهم جواهر
اكتشف المطعم اخر المطاف انه يدافع اربعين
خمسين بالميه على الطلب
مبالغ فلكيه ولا هي اساسا تغطي تكاليف
الطلب اللي عليه يعني للمستمع ما يعرف
النقطه هذه المطعم الان اليوم ممكن يدفع
ما بين حسب حجم المطعم طبعا بس ممكن يدفع
كنسبه للتطبيق التوصيل عن كل طلب نسبه ما
بين خلينا نقول كمتوسط عشره الى 20 25%
هذا في السعوديه لكن لما تروح مثلا مثل
الكويت والامارات لا وصلت الى 30%
و33% وهذا راح يتم فيه تصاعد مستمر غير
النسبه في ايضا لو انت المطعم تبي تدخل من
ضمن البرنامج الاشتراك هذا اللي خلي الناس
تطلبون منك توصيل مجاني اللي بيرفع
الطلبات بتحتاج ايضا تدفع رسوم اضافيه على
كل طلب صحيح انا لو اطلب اليوم من اي مطعم
بيبسي ولا ثلاث بيبسي وفعلين قاعد يدفع لي
خسران بشكل كبير على الطلب غير شذي لما
اذا تبي تصير مثلا بالتطبيق تكون واضح فوق
راح تدفع على على على والظهور لتحسين
ظهورك لتحسين ظهورك غير شذي اي اي حمله
تسويقيه يسويها التطبيق وانت تخش فيها لان
تبي تكون عندك ظهور اكثر اهم التشويه نصف
النص ففي مبالغ كثيره تندفع
الرابح الاخير وبالتطبيق المطعم ما هو
مستفيد ولا الزبون مستفيد لانه قاعد يدفع
رسوم التوصيل بشكل كبير وقاعد يدفع يعني
امور ثانيه بشكل كبير وهذا الشيء يعني من
تركت انا كرج كان دائما في بالي يعني طبعا
انا يوم تركت خارج لو تسالني تقول لي الدش
مره ثانيه بالتطبيقات التوصيل الاكل اقول
لك مستحيل مستحيل خلاص
الخاطر وخلاص يعني اذكر كريم قد جتهم فتره
شهريا زي الاشتراك على الموبايل بس مدري
كملوا كل تطبيق حاول انه يشوف طريقه انه
يغير من طريقه
البزنس
نموذج العمل لكن
بالاخير اربح شيء وهو موضوع النسب عرفت
شلون لانه نسبه انا احبك واعزك انت كمطعم
راح اعطيك نسبه زينه المطعم ثاني هذا ارفع
عليه النسبه وكل سنه عن سنه اقدر ارفع
عليه وانا مرتاح عرفت شلون انه في مطاعم
يعني خلصت المطاعم الصغيره تكون معتمده
بشكل كبير
مثل
اعوذ بالله المخدرات قديش التطبيق انت
كمطعم تاخذ اول فكس عندك
مبيعات يصير فيك واو شو هالمبيعات
لا ممتاز ابي استمر وياهم هيك الشهر
الثاني في مبيعات ثانيه بنفس الوقت شو
يصير قاعد يخف عندك الدخول داخل مطعم
الناس اللي
المطعم عندك وتطلب منك فيصير اعتمادك اكثر
على التطبيق من يصير اعتمادك اكثر على
التطبيق تبلش تفكر بطريق طرق ثانيه ان انت
النسبه اللي ياخذونها منك
تقللها كثر ما تقدر شو تسوي
تقلد تكاليف اقصد شو تسوي تبلش تفكر انه
يبغى انا ليش فاتح مطعم
عود خلني اروح مثلا
[موسيقى]
ادشن تكاليفي اقل موظفيني اقل
يصير اعتمادك هنا اكثر على التطبيق لانه
ماكو واحد راح يطلب منك بعدين يصير فيك
لحظه يبغى انا ليش مثلا قاعد ادفع هالنسبه
خلني ارفع سعر تكلفه الوجبه واخلي العميل
يدفع جزء من النسبه وانا ادفع نسمه ما اخر
شيء الا انت قاعد تدفع او او قاعد تدفع
العميل النهائي جزء كبير من النسبه اللي
قاعد ياخذها التطبيق وانت بنفس الوقت دشيت
يسمونه القرقور دشيت القرقورنا خلاص
القرقور اول مره ترجم
يصير مثل اداه صيد يحطونها بالبحر
السمكه اذا دشت فيها ما تقدر تطلع
فعاده ياخذون مثل يكون شبك بطريقه معينه
ينحط نصف البحر وفي طعم داخله السمكه تدش
ويكون يعني مفتوح فتحه كبيره بعدين تضيق
داخل فمن الدش السمكه داخل ما تقدر تشوف
طريق انه هي تطلع منها فنفس الطريقه انت
السمكه والمطعم المطعم السمكه ودش داخل
ومسمي الحلقه قرقور التطبيقات
فهذه مشكله ايضا مطاعم ثانيه غير ما بنقول
نعمم على جميع المطاعم في مطاعم يقول لك
برفع سعر الوجبات على اساس اني اقدر اعوض
النسبه هذه ما عندك تطبيقات ما يسمحون حسب
علمي انه تعطي سعر اعلى للتطبيق وتبيعه في
المطعم بسعر يفضلون انك تقدر المساله ما
تقدر
التطبيق حسب علمي يجبرك تحط نفس السعر لكن
المطاعم تلعبون صح ايضا في مطاعم وهذا من
حقهم يعني ما هو تلاعب اللي يقول لك انا
الوجبات اللي سعرها عالي مراحل صناديق
البوكسز الكبيره ما راح احطها لان ممكن
يكون سعرها غالي لكنها نفس حجم الوجبه
وكذا ما عندي استعداد
مع التطبيق شيء فهل هذه المشكله كانت حفزك
ترجع فهذه مشكله كبيره وهذا اللي خلاني
ابلش افكر بالموضوع بشكل جدي
فقعدت افكر بالموضوع يعني ما هو منطقي
اللي قاعد يصير
بالتوصيل المطاعم يعني بهالطريقه ما راح
يستمر مستحيل انه يستمر المطعم ما راح يتم
يدفع 30 واربعين وممكن يوصل 50% خلال
السنين القادمه مستحيل انه يستمر
بهالطريقه المطاعم اغلبها خسرانه ولو تسال
اي مطعم انت مرتاح في التطبيق موجود
التطبيقات في الوضع الحالي بيقول لك لا
ماني مرتاح داش وياي كشريك ياخذ مني كانه
قاعد ياخذ نسبه ضريبه ما هو هذا
فصار فيني اكيد في طريقه افضل الواحد ممكن
خلقت مشكله ورجعت
فعلا جزء من المشكله لكن فعلا كان يبي لها
حل فبلشنا نفكر بموضوع شلون ممكن نحل
الموضوع شلون نقدر لانه حتى يمكن انت يوم
بديت كان الوضع اسهل بس حتى التطبيقات صار
يرتفع عليه التكاليف صرت تبغى ترفع النسبه
يعني الطرفين ماكلينها بموضوع
التطبيقات بشكل كبير ويعني اغلبها شركات
مدرجه وهذا خير دليل انه هي شركه ربحانه
يعني فقط الموضوع قاعد يصير ان يعني يبون
يربحون بشكل أزيد وصار في توجه كبير من
المطاعم ايش قاموا يسوون اغلبهم يتوجهون
ويسوي تطبيق يسوي الويب سايت بروحه
اساس ان الناس تطلب دايركتي يكتشف انه
يتكلف بشكل كبير على اساس انه يستحو
العملاء وزباين عرفت شلون فصار فيه من انه
كان في
ان المطعم نفسه هو اللي يسوي التطبيق اللي
يجمع المطاعم
بس منطقين ينزل
اذا انت مطعم كبير اللي دائما الناس
يطلبون منه ممكن او انت مثلا هذا المطعم
تطلب منه ثلاث اربع مرات بالاسبوع ممكن
انه انت تنزل هالتطبيق لكن فعليا بشكل عام
وجود التطبيقات وهو يساعد ويحفز ان انت
تدش مره ثانيه وثلاثه وعشره وعشرين وتعتمد
عليه انها كزبون انت تطلب منه والمشكله
هذه مره
المشكله هذه اللي خلتها تبغى ترجع فهذه
المشكله اللي خلتني ابلش افكر ان انا ارجع
مره ثانيه بالفود دليفري
فهني هنا يعني بلشت الفكره صار فيني ليش
ما بلش انا افكر الموضوع بطريقه مختلفه
نموذج العمل وغيره بطريقه نموذج الايراد
لو غيره بطريقه بحيث انه تخدم المطعم
وتخدم العميل النهائي بطريقه منا حق
الجميع وحتى حق التطبيق نفسه ممكن انه
يكون فيه حق الكل اللي حصل قررت ان انا
بداله ادش في موضوع ان انا اخوض التجربه
من يده بنفس طريقه التطبيقات هذه قررت انه
ندش في طريقه مختلفه تماما بطريقه ببساطه
جدا
اتشرج المطعم
المطعم يدفع فقط على اول طلب الى من
العميل يعني على سبيل المثال اليوم مشهور
طلب من
حلو اول مره ماكدونالدز يدفع قيمه
قيمه معينه حق مشهور نسبه ولا مبلغ ثابت
يا مشهور طلب مره ثانيه ما يدفع مره ثالثه
ما يدفع له ولا شيء مره رابع ما يدفع عليه
قرر المشهور بيطلب
يدفع عفوا اول مره على مشهور لكن يتملكها
حق فتره معينه فش يصير هنا يصير انه
ماكدونالدز بطبيعه الحال لانه يملك مشهور
بطبيعه الحال يبي يسوق حق مشهور ويحفسه
انه فقط يطلب من التطبيق اللي لانه ما
قاعد يدفع على كل طلب بعد الاول اوكي بس
بعد كل طلب بعد الاول للابد ما راح فتره
زمنيه معينه
يا سنه يا ثلاث سنين عندنا العاقدين نشتغل
فيه فالمده سنه
يعني انت انت كانه احنا ايش قاعد نسوي
كانه المطعم صار عنده الويب سايت او
التطبيق ماله بروحه من خلال ابلكيشن فهمت
لمده سنه
او عطله الخيار هذا حق السنه انه مشهور
جاء طلب منك بمبلغ عفوا طلب منك اي طلب
انت المطعم بتدفع التطبيق مبلغ ثابت واذا
رجع مشهور طلب ثاني وثالث ورابع وخامس مره
طول السنه طول السنه واذا حتى لو طلبت طلب
نهايه السنه حتى لو طلبت سنه
الاولى وطلب بدايه السنه الثانيه يدفع
مرتين لان احنا ايش قاعد نسوي هني قاعد
نحاول ان احنا ويممك الطريقه اللي يصير
فيها
فقدان العملاء عرفت شلون اليوم لما لما
انت تستقطب العميل بطبيعه الحال ما يستمر
العميل وياك الى ابد لابتين في فتره معينه
خلاص يقرروا ذوقه يتغير طريقه تتغير ممكن
يكون ايا كان ممتاز المطاعم بس انت
بالنسبه لك ليش بالطريقه هذه عميل مثلا
وتصور ناس كثير زي كذا عندهم احنا ثلاث
اربع مطاعم بالكثير هي اللي يطلب منها
بشكل متكرر انت فعليا بتاخذ اربع اربع
مرات وبعدها اطلب الله سهل عليهم بالف
عافيه المطعم لان شنو الفكره الفكره انه
لما لما يجي مقلك مشهور ويبيه يطلب منه
مره ثانيه وثالثه ورابع وهو اكيد راح يحفز
انه يطلع بس انت مش تستفيد فانا استفيد
اني مشهور اقدر اخليه يجرب اربع خمس ست
عشر مطاعم بطريقتي احفزه انه يجرب مطاعم
ثانيه والمطعم نفسه يحفز مشهور انه يطلب
من مطعمه فاصبح شنو اصبح بحكم ان انا
التحفيز مالي انه يجرب مطاعم مختلفه تحفيز
مقدار الزناوه يستمر وياه صار فيه
ديسكاونتس بشكل دايم على التطبيق صار فيه
تحفيز حق مشهور انه يستمر يطلب من تطبيق
كاري وليس من تطبيقات بس تكون مرهقه عليك
اذا المطعم قاعد يحفز العميل انه يطلب
باستمرار وانت قاعد توصل وانت قاعد ابدا
ابدا اوه شو اللي حصل يحصل تكلفه احنا ايش
قاعد نحاول نسوي قاعد نحاول ان احنا نخلق
نفس البيئه لو ان المطعم بيسوي تطبيق هو
بروحه فلو المطعم بيسوي تطبيق بيتكفل
بالتوصيل هو بيتكفل بالتسويق وهو بيتكفل
بانه يسوي التطبيق
ويطوره فاحنا ايش يسوي ياه انه يوصل الطلب
يا ان احنا نوفر له التوصيل بالتكلفه
عرفت شلون فيصير كانه احنا قاعد
نخلق نفس البيئه لو انه قاعد يسوي تطبيق
ممكن الزبون يدفعها كنوع من رسوم التوصيل
وهو يدفع جزء منها ويصير فيه او هو اتفاق
بينه وبين العميل يعني هو يتفاهم ويا
العمل النهائي عرفت شلون
فهني قدرنا ان احنا نحل مشكله انه النسب
قاعد تزيد بتصاعد مستمر بطبيعه الحال لانه
مقدار يتملك مشهور حق فتره زمنيه سنه او
ثلاث سنين بطبيعه الحال كل ما يطلب مشهور
كل ما قلت اتكاليف مالتها بداله تزيد مع
الوقت عرفت شلون طبعا في امور مختلفه
ثانيه احنا نوفرها حق المطعم طريق انه
يسوق حق مشهور هيوفر يعني هذا الشيء ما هو
موجود
تربح بالسنوات الجايه
او على الاقل لقدام هل بس من اول طلب هذا
اللي بتحاول تتنوع طلبات العملاء بشكل
يضمن انك قاعد تحقق ربح ولا انه فيه ايه
شوف يعني
صيغه السؤال مع شمال تطبيق لسه جديد
كيف ممكن تحفز العميل يطلب من اماكن ثانيه
ما عمره اجربها ولا يعني لو اي تجربه فيها
انا خلاص انا اعرف هذا وهذا مطاعم تعود
عليها وحبها ليش اروح اجرب احنا احنا مو
بس عدلنا
طريقه العمل اللي هو البزنس عدلنا حتى
البرودكت انه يسمح لنا احنا نبين حق مشهور
بطريقه معينه بانس معين مطاعم وهموم
مجربها مطاعم تكون قرية عنده اقبال اكثر
انه يعني انت اليوم لا تبطل الانستجرام
تشوف الاكسبلور حسب اهتمامك انت مو حسب
اهتمام اي شخص ثاني عرفت شلون فهذه هذا
الطريقه ان انت اليوم مثلا دائما تطلب راح
يطلع لك في الغالب فارس فود بشكل دائم
عرفت شلون راح يطلع لك ان انت ايش رايك
تجرب هالمطعم
فيصير اعلى بالنسبه حق المطاعم اللي عندك
قابليه اكثر انها تطلب منها
انك انت تروج المطاعم ثاني
عرفت شلون ما راح ابين لك مثلا سوشي وانت
بس اطلب فاس فود والعكس صحيح
هذه طريقه تحفيز ان احنا فاحنا غيرنا
البرودكت صار بداله انه هو التطبيق يستفيد
من ان انت تكون فوق لا انا ابني بطريقه
بحيث انه الانسب لك كزبون نهائي واللي انت
تشوفه مختلف على اللي انا اشوفه مختلف عن
اي شخص ثاني يشوفك اساسا احنا نقدر نحفز
بس نسبه من اول ثلاث طلبات كل شهر
لا
بس يعني وش اللي يخلي الموضوع بالنسبه لك
غير قابل للاستنساخ والله يعني صار لنا
شهر ونصف
اللي احنا شغالين فيه يعني بالاخير الفكره
شنو الفكره انه لما انت تستحوذ على
العملاء
المطاعم راح يصير فيها انا ليش قاعد رده
ادفع مره ثانيه حق تطبيق ثاني
خلاص انا استحوذ استحوذت على العملاء ما
راح تشوي اي تطبيق ثاني انه يتعامل بنفس
الموديل هذا عرفت شلون حتى لو يطلع تطلع
تطبيقات ثانيه انا عندي عندي عملائي في
تطبيق كاري
يعني من غير منطقي ان انا ادش في في في
تطبيقات اخرى تستخدم نفس الموديل على فكره
[موسيقى]
فكره الاسم كانت انه يعني في
ايام كرج
حرف الكاف دائما يكون مميز بالنسبه حق
الناس يعني تذكره اسرع من اي يعني هذا
فلما كاري كارج هذي امور تكون شويه رنانه
بالنسبه
قبل
الواحد يشيل ويعني
اشتغلنا فيه شغالين فيه حاليا بلشنا بشهر
11 بالكويت وتبارك الرحمن يعني كانت
انطلاقه جدا موفقه
[موسيقى]
في في غض شهرين
وهذا يدل على انه معناته ان الموديل شغال
وشغال بطريقه ربي لك الحمد جدا ممتازه
اليوم انا عندي مطاعم 70% من طلباتها 70%
من طلباتها ما قاعد تدفع عليها ولا ريال
رسوم
فيوريك انه شلون فيه اهتمام كبير من
العميل بالنسبه حق بعض المطاعم وانت على
طول السعوديه مباشره بلشتك على طول وراها
السعوديه والفكره انه مثل ما يعني ذكرت لك
انا يعني سوق السعودي سوق ناشئ ولا ما تم
للسحب هذا عليه بشكل كبير وقاعد يصير فيه
توسع بشكل كبير يعني انا بالنسبه لي من
غير المنطقي اليوم
السوق السعودي حجمه تقريبا ضعفين او ثلاث
اضعاف في السوق الكويتي لكن فعليا
نسبه او كنسبه
مكان في السعوديه هو تقريبا عشر اضعاف
فنشوف في فرصه على الرغم من ضخامه
المنافسين الموجودين
باذن الله فالحلو بالموضوع لانه موديل
جديد
فانا عندي قناه عنا هذه ممكن تكون شركه ما
هي فقط خليجيه لكن شركه عالميه باذن الله
واذا جاك احد بيشتري بعد سنه
ما قصرت
هذي ان شاء الله يعني بالنسبه لنا يعني
نبي نبي يعني شركه فعلا نشوفها كشركه ممكن
تكون عالميه
يعني بالنسبه لي اللي سووه مثلا تطبيق
جاهز الله يوفقهم يستاهلون كل خير شيء
صراحه يثرج الصدر ومثل ينضرب فيه
[موسيقى]
اجتهاد وسعه وقدروا انهما يسوون يعني شيء
مميز فتره يعني ما هي طويله وهذا يدللنا
يعني سوق فيه قبال والسوق محتاج انه يكون
فيه هذه الشركات الناشئه اللي ممكن توصل
صراحه نشوف وش سرعه تجربتكم لانه اعتقد
قطاع المطاعم او خلنا نقول التوصيل
للطلبات بشكل عام يحتاج احد يجي يعيد
تشكيله من جديد
كل ما يعني سنه عن سنه كل ما التطبيقات
يرفعون النسب يرفعون الرسوم ويرفعون ما
اعتقد ان نموذج يعني
مستدام ما هو شيء تكمل عليه الفتره طويله
ابدا فحلو انكم يعني
متاكدون غيركم ممكن يخففون شوي من الرسوم
النسب او على الاقل يعني الله يرزقهم
ويرزق الجميع بس يفكرون بطرق مبتكره تساعد
في انهم في علاقه الطرفين كلهم مستفيدين
شوفوا هذا اللي حاصله وهو يعني
المنافسه جدا ممتازه بالنسبه حق المطاعم
بالنسبه حق الزبون النهائي ممتازه بالنسبه
لنا
انت تفكر بطرق مختلفه عرفت
النسب ما هي ما فيها شطاره تعالي اعطيك 15
عشرين انا اعطيك اربعه عشرة موضوع ما
الشطاره وين الشطاره ان انت تقدر فعلا
توفر قيمه مضافه بالنسبه حق المطعم
وبالنسبه حق العميل النهائي وشلون توفر
هالقيمه المضافه توفرها بطريقه بحيث انه
حتى مع الوقت يصير في استمراريه السوق
لانه بهالحاله
هو اللي قاعد يصير قاعد يصير فيه تضييق
تضييق للسوق بشكل كبير انت لما التطبيقات
هذه تزيد النسب المطاعم خلاص قاعد تنعصر
بطريقه بحيث انه ما قاعد تربح بالاخير فهو
فعليا التطبيقات قاعد تصغر عليها السوق
بطريقه لا اراديه
الاشياء اللي تسويها تطبيقات التوصيل
اليوم لانها تاخذ هالنسبه بمثال تعويض
العملاء اذا صار في مشكله في الطلب واذا
صار في اي شيء في المطعم
مشاكلك انت اللي بتكفل
يعني اي عميل نهائي لما التطبيق راح
يشوفها حاله من حاله اي تطبيق ثاني فيه
والتوصيل يوصل لك
بالنسبه
والامور هذي كلها لكن وين الاختلاف
لاختلاف بالبي توبي البزنس وبيزنس انا
كبزنس اعطي المطعم
ما يعطيها التطبيقات الثانيه يعني اول مره
اعطي صلاحيه حق المطعم انه يكون عنده
اكسس على العملاء اللي عنده عنده عنده
يقدر يقدر
مثلا مشهور طالب من مطعمه يقدروه يوصل له
مثلا معين يقدر يوصل له اوفر معين خاص فيه
خاص في مشهور لان التطبيقات في الوقت
الحالي ما يهمه مشهور طلب ماكدونالدز
تطبيقات اللي توفر حلول للمطاعم بشكل
تدمج اثنين
هذه الفكره الله يوفقكم عبد الله وسعيد
جدا اليوم
جزاك الله خير جزاك الله خير مشكور على
اللقاء وما قصرتم الله يعطيكم العافيه
حبيبي الله يعافيك قبل ما تقفل الحلقه
اتمنى اذا اعجبتك تشاركها مع لحولك
وتقيمها بتقييم ايجابي سواء في اليوتيوب
او في ايتونز واذا كان عندكم ملاحظات عنها
سواء على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ات 8.com
او حتى على حسابي في تويتر
شكرا لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد سعيد في اعداد
الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره التصوير
بالاضاءه غالب محمد ومساعده ياسر في
الاخراج البدائي وهاب موسى في الاخراج
الفني مسجد القرشي والهندسه الصوتيه عبد
العزيز المزي التحرير برامج بيبان في
التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر عبد الله بن
الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز او في الانتاج
التنفيذي رزان دهيثم هذا
منتجات شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]